me dit tu me dis est ce que tu veux pas
qu'on essaie d'appeler cristiano ronaldo
puis juste bonjour c'est blaise et c'est
tout on t'aime voilà c'est tout on
rappelle que tu es là pour ton
association merci d'être venu nous voir
vraiment et on va essayer d'aider au
mieux l'association de blaise alors je
vous dis chacun va paix qu'est ce qui
vous connaissez vous je peux essayer
giroux olivier giroud et de pédaler ap
le titre olivier girault si vous l'avez
ses 100 euros allez c'est bon c'est bon
football alors c'est pas forcément
foutoir benhaim c'est qui djibril cissé
ah oui pas mal beau rocco connais pas il
est pas tout voleur mêmes et marque
beaucoup de buts
ça s'appelle olivier giroud donc les
noirs benjamin castaldi et son bord
calmes très peu de chose qui répond
bravo quoi voilà merci bombe alors n'en
sait pas plus mais en fait l'animal et
cinq ans djibril cissé va répondre bah
répondent à beinheim il va dire
peut-être elle veut me pécho un truc
comme ça
quoique narcisse 17 va pas répondre
excuse moi tu mettras ça après te plaît
bah oui c'est dur interne émission
hockey troisième sonnerie tu auras
blaise but c'est de voir que l'équipe
est bonne reste à l'eau message laurent
à les appliquer ou barocco rocco
siffredi vous ça va décrocher tu vas
résident préparez vos numéros d'appel
c'est frais c'est qui ces frères voisine
ans et une batte de dire non il est
peut-être en train de bosser assortis à
[Rires]
budapest
ça serait bien mais il va répondre j'ai
rencontré poncet s'emballe alors j'ai
perdu répondre mais comment tu as sans
doute décroche c'est pas bête
ouais vous êtes vraiment respectifs
avant d'appliquer celle de sailly mais
il est au ghana alors on essaye david
azie impact direct
sayyed en métal tu as préparé numéro et
que derrag à laval et kelly maintenant
j'ai hâte m hatem ben arfa vas-y appel à
près d'athènes mais il est encore au
foot on sait pas qui vient de sortir
c'est pas possible
hatem ben arfa les voit kelly b2b dit de
dire la nasa c'est vrai avec un singe
appelé personne à temps j'ai appelé ma
croûte alors n'ont toujours pas vraiment
au taquet doit passer lahbib el habib
bouakeul plus a dit vas-y vas-y lgv a
répondu j'espère les mecs vous rendez
compte qu'il ya personne car ils
inquiètent cas moi ça va répondre
abidjan 5 euros chez avec ma blouse là
tu dis on en direct sur tp mp avec cyril
hanouna
comment tu vas cette rubrique bah ça va
très bien on y est ça va on est là pour
l'association de blaise matuidi
bon bah lui c'est bon c'est samba l'euro
a baissé
merci depuis mon cas on a du prix qui
serait versé à sa marque et surtout ils
embrassent leur et en direct avec
ghislaine là et avec eux blaise matuidi
ça va bien qu'on a gagné son balcon
grâce à toi grâce à toi on a gagné 100
euros pour l'association de blaise
matuidi il fallait appeler un sportif
donc j'étais appelé passe partout qui
sait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'ils appelèrent il a nous a pondu
bisou qui candeloro
[Rires]
m
apple s'est parlé on peut déjà fait les
choses bien plus carteron ils ont pas
voulu
j'adore carteron carteron louis babel
qui vous voulez mais après quelques
doutes tu peux applications d'autres non
mais attendez attendez attendez pas à
voir des complots mois moi je vais
essayer d'abord mathieu vous a plu
nelson monfort moi j'appelle une norme
star c'est bon alors rappelle énorme
star il me doit beaucoup en plus je
pense qu'il va répondre c'est qu'il
pense que vous allez voir c'est une
surprise parce que jamais dit ça tu
expliques tu vas pleurer êtes non ménard
midi qui s'est dit d'horaires regardes
tu faire respecter moi respecte le sur
trois gars il va paraître monde s'est tu
vas pas répondre il doit tout alors si
tu avais dit qu'il sait pas ce que je
peux rajouter c'est alors tu peux aller
sur 1000 tu parles sûrement l'insee un
poteau à l'eau ouais mon frère ces
matous
[Applaudissements]
comment tu vas
la cellule
j'ai hâte et marion marion laon
là-dedans l'union leur fasse oui qu'est
qui vous avez vous jamais qui va mais là
candeloro vous là mais j'ai laissé un
message
jibril à personne je paye direct moi
même mais non mais non mais non mesdames
et messieurs ça tu peux pas appeler
teddy riner teddy riner mais je ne
l'appelais répond pas fallait la louer
cet aprem fossiles et grandir alors les
chéris moi je propose est ce que tu veux
que j'appelle je vais essayer d'appeler
antoine griezmann blesse chez cedar
euros pour page comme alors là on a 1000
euros et blaise est ce que tu veux pas
tu me dis tu me dis est ce que tu veux
pas qu'on essaie d'appeler cristiano
ronaldo puis juste bonjour c'est blaise
et c'est tout on t'aime voilà c'est tout
comme si cette gêne ne le fait pas je
vais essayer d'appeler gaiman déjà mais
cristiano ronaldo les mecs là c'est mal
barré rota numéro nom est pleine nuit il
joue avec lui avec la braise me fais
tourner féraud
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle s'appelle antoine j'appelle au punk
the man from a envoyé un message peut
pas décrocher la tête dans le cube
[Applaudissements]
c'est un témoin interrogé à des rôles où
on était bel et bien là on est à 1100
euros alors je vous dis voit les choses
et numéros en plus de personnes ne
connaît mon numéro donc ça doit répondre
j'ai essayé d'appeler antoine je vais
essayer d'appeler antoine voilà les
mânes la très bonne équipe en fait on
attendait quand on analyse anne oui
c'est un amour c'est bien ça peu court
en ce moment un peu plus long comme ça
c'est pas mal ça devienne beaucoup et
bien non ça sonne aibo société bout amer
c'est vrai ouais ça va ça va et vous
ressembler un peu mais bon on a un qui a
du talent alors bye est pas disponible
voilà pour l'instant on à 1100 euros et
sa dernière je peux essayer mais ben ça
sera pas cristiano mais je peut
s'effectuer ces pays et qu'ils s'y
sentent humiliés mamadou sakho va très
bien a dit mme baddou et je pense qu'il
en scooter la zeebo blaise et et vous
voulez essayer quand tu rames il ya
turan pas mal basij et ça pas mal ici
toi tu as tord attendait encore finie on
finit b saint andré s'est pas candeloro
non
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est vrai matuidi
moi je suis sur le plateau de thé pmp là
avec céline sésame en direct là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon voeu de gaza attends je ne
sais pas si tout le monde tu entends
c'est bien d'avoir enfoui
[ __ ] mamadou aux boules et embrasser
mon frère fait ses comptes m
voilà et on doit se dire est on avec
blaise qui est exceptionnel on voulait
faire un énorme bisou antenne formé dans
la disgrâce perron je t'embrasse fort
bragg matignon
[Musique]